[Applause]
Euronext
that's an unusual one what mr. Scamander
fears above everything else is having to
work in an office sir
newts biggest fear is working in an
office y-yeah well so what's your Bhagat
what is your greatest fear you know I've
seen Malthus and I was thinking that one
is legitimately it's a really good one
see I love offices I might be love an
office I love stationery I have a weird
obsession with stationery I never really
liked a smokeless yes escape this whole
punch so that's definitely not my fear
and ibly is deep water like really deep
water but I don't know how that would
manifest itself because it smell but
just realize I've had an epiphany mine's
probably mess yeah I I think messy a
messy room although it would have to be
a vision of my room just found that
thing in the world wants to see that
piece destroyed
let's take it
the shooting that scene can you walk me
through it being there what was real
what was not we've got Johnny Depp and
he's being super serious he was real
almost magic was real it's all things
that do on this film I think sometimes
people think on these beast films that a
lot of it's done in CGI and there's a
certain what they've built they
literally built that amphitheater and
there were thousands of supporting
artists dressed as like wizards from all
over the place what I found amazing in
that scene is Johnny is having tonight
speak this great rhetoric intense
rhetoric to this massive crowd but he
also manages to sort of charm and sort
of seduce the camera around also what
are you a phantom ah ah he's a master of
I think he had a vision that he would
rise to dominance over the Wizarding
World
so you're asking me to help hunt him
down
I also was watching the behind the
scenes and you have this shocked wing
where you literally climb out of the
goddamn suitcase yeah like I he makes it
look easy what they're amazing
is there a hole this is the true magic
again Catherine hates it when I give
away the secrets but there was one thing
that when we did the first filming no
trying to work out how noot gets into
the case should that be some kind of
gravitational thing and JK Rowling was
really specific but it should be
old-school there should be steps you
should walk down so one of those and
thank you for also just doing it do you
also we do add extra steps because you
come up the ladder but then sometimes
for the camera they need a few more so
you do the real steps and then sometimes
you kind of go I can't move again
spindle fault it has to be you in your
shoes I'd probably refused to there's
late did he mean it no I heard that you
went back and you watched the old Harry
Potter I mean what a great excuse sure
exactly well so what was changing I was
at work you know it's eating popcorn and
chocolate got problems this is they are
making their tum notes sounds pretty
good to me what are the greatest gifts
that you got from watching Richard
Harris and also Michael Gambon because
they're portrayals I mean everything is
very humor I think there's a humor and a
twinkle in in actually that they both
has it have as actors anyway but they
just bring to their most of their
performances there's a sort of yeah
sense of humor
even in in in intense and and dire
situations and a warmth
warms in there I really wanted to make
sure I carried on and in view this this
sense of a good heart at the center of
this man even despite all his
complications in his turmoil that he's I
think feeling a little more in this film
to perhaps at the age 100 between 10
Catherine and I call it the Dumbledore
twinkle wish you'd recite in the first
look he gave me
CGI King you guys have to take your
sunglasses off give it over to magic
brooms only in rare Souls
stealing sculpting shadows what is your
no mines simple I am actually a
terrifying snake I did a snake in this
movie so you play one and I I was I was
hearing that you had you went and
visited snakes you realized they maybe
weren't as bad as you originally thought
yes they don't attack unless they're
attacked first they're beautiful and so
soft but I'm still horrified of Nagini
and there was this mini figurine at the
studio tour I wanted it so bad but it
was so scary looking I didn't get it but
she's halfway into this bizarre type of
aversion therapy you know and I mean
where's she's essentially like faced her
fear not to her tone but the truth yes I
see snakes in my dreams every day since
she did the role snake farms and my
dreams snake yeah I don't know just the
last thing that's the snake farm I've
started for you I didn't want to tell
you about it before but we do have the
snake farm ready for you in every Europe
where you're ready to be their king yeah
okay so there's something that you need
to get out in this course of zones
there's something that there's something
that you're processing I don't know what
it is yeah but don't we don't we already
know I mean come on snakes
tell me snakes they're awesome and
they're
most sacred animistic symbols in the
living world that's true and the
Occidental faith tried to turn us
against them you know what I mean forget
that forget that noise only time the
word Occidental ever used in one of my
interviews I just want to note it
we're the only people you should ever
interview you're the only person you
should ever interview us and we should
only do it here road trip road trip to
nowhere
we're already there all right I also
heard that you didn't know exactly we
were auditioning for so take me to that
moment that you got the script inside no
no no no it was before that so it was
the scene where we were together in
London David was there I was there to
read with him and then he dropped it and
said you're a Nagini and it's like I
can't make a fool out of myself in front
of Ezra Miller myself together have you
retracted that statement at all to
impress me sometime and this is
videotape rudimental I had to do the
transformation and that went how
okay I have to find the tape and
distraction I have some courtroom
sketches if you're watching this please
please send it back to me let's just
wrap this up by all just doing our best
snake like a shimmy I don't know it's
just what I feel like doing right now
[Laughter]
are you getting my god you should have
been Nikki that's what I try to tell me
disposable
you could meet you never met a monster
you couldn't process was toward the
rendered the rally I mean everything was
there except for the fire oh yeah safety
risk how long did that take the shoot to
reach two weeks yeah I was a lot
everyone started off there and then we
sectioned off yes it's a big so when you
are not shooting that your particular
shots in such a big scene like are you
still there watching everything you do
at the beginning so you get an idea of
what's going on geography yeah I'm in
your eyes and then by the end for Johnny
well there's a point where we had a
recording of his voice right towards the
very end you know there oh yeah he gave
it every time I reckon he was behind the
wall he was talking [ __ ] like Wizard
of Oz you know I love that like this
hearing just hearing his voice is every
bit as creepy as seeing that character I
feel like actually and he was speaking
very quietly when he would do it which
actually made it really great but it but
sometimes hard to hear so where we are
in your life in the way that is the way
Johnny just speak out thank you sorry
right make them come to you it's
actually that's exactly what it is
Oh Doctrine I guess I don't have to yell
come to me totally really cool choice I
cream speaking of sexy answers we're
calling him Dumble
[Laughter]
and he always felt it says how he's
finally looks as hot as he's felt I
guess he always knew that he was hot hot
so that even picked out yeah
name a movie characters that you love
that you'd love to see as a young hot
version hmm what age we talking at like
22 you tell me 99 Hagrid
I really want to like sit down for
longer and explore your Hagrid answer hi
grid you know no beard maybe it's like a
shape top ha hair and like a Santa Claus
like sexy Santa Claus right I mean in
this outfit Timothy sha'lame to play
Santa Claus and let him borrow your
fabulous no I'm alive but I'm an
alchemist and therefore immortal oh
you're gonna fly man J koalas oh oh you
don't look a day over 375 in which I
want to know what your Bob is yep porta
potties porta potti I deeply relate to
them yeah yeah I mean like if one showed
up and a spell like I'd be really really
unhappy about it
GSA pat-downs at the airport I feel bad
for people when I see that happening
like what are you carrying yeah it's
even worse when they're just padding
your inseam and go you're Jack black
aren't you
it happens all the time and I'm like
wait a minute yes I am sir yes sure but
can we do subject from the location
describe to me this so the climactic
scene the big rally is so amazing right
now what's real and what's not
did you feel uncomfortable because if
anyone knew who you really were right
besides your buddies ready I would have
been toasted
I don't want to spoil anything wrong we
had 550 extras that
or those days so it was packed and the
energy was strange how so well it felt
like you know they were there for that
the scene itself was a very secretive
scene everyone's meeting in secret you
know in the catacombs of this you know
cemetery and so that alone it's so
freaky right
yeah and just like the people that they
brought in and that they chose everybody
really dug into this outcasts kind of
people coming together so there was a
strange sort of uneasy energy already
yeah in the room and then we had you
know but then we had Johnny speaking and
you know that was stirring the pot
stirring the pot and it was very very
strange and powerful and yes it's not a
bad day at the office I think when you
just watching Johnny Depp with two
different colored eyes and that glorious
hair is just making people man that
stuff making people yeah inviting them
and
he's very good he's very good he's a
good bad guy you know you need a good
bad guy for a movie to work you know you
need a really and he's really good yeah
yeah yeah Johnny Depp I've heard of him
he's yeah he's a very talented boy the
only character that wasn't there
young hot Dumbledore I just want to
focus on that awkwardly for a second
okay
what movie character throughout time
would you like to see as a young hot
version of themselves you know Jimmy
Stewart and it's wonderful life Wow
wait yeah well in his teens I mean not
even that much younger but just like
considering it's such an old movie you
know like I just liked it to meet like a
current age because actually the
flashbacks in that movie are so great
I second this where it's like that would
be great to see more of that yeah
crumbles I know those battles I can't
help it if you start saying that I got
into reality Dan is it super easier to
be in a relationship when you've had
your memory erased yeah at the end of
the night just can you remember your
race and everything's fine yeah no yeah
that's a tricky exactly that's exactly I
accept I accept I'm drew Barrymore I
like that I like that movie I'd see that
movie
it's another person all confused before
later
I got a little crush on her so weird hey
are you listening drew drew I've had a
crush on you for a long time ever since
Wayne's World
I mean that's a weird example else
[Music]